we mutated and we'll try to screen it
and see if any of the mutants from this
molecule can sense what which inside the
cells library was up to ten millions up
ten millions individual cones screening
of each cell manually takes several
minutes so it means I wouldn't be able
to finish probably the screen covers
library till nowadays if I start doing
it manually and was saying oh how about
we just make robot to do it for us and
this is how we end up designing a
special robot but can image very large
population of a cells automatically pick
the best cells expressing voltage
sensing molecule and selected using a
micropipette and everything in in
automated mode in fully automated mode I
remember this day when I click start it
took me about two years to make it to
happen but once it's everything was set
we click start button robot did it for
us for two hours by always drinking
coffee that when do this process I take
wear tube with a few cells like this
from a plate I clone the genes and one
of them was the arcon voltage sensor
which we currently using for voltage
imaging in vivo boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Alan
Saki on we are on site at MIT
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
beautiful Cambridge Massachusetts
we are now going to be talking about
neural imaging and interfacing we have
dr. Kiel pH image joining us on the show
hello good afternoon thank you so much
for coming on really appreciate it I'm
very excited also very grateful to see
Renu SH for introducing us about Canova
thank you you've shoutout for those that
don't know curious background he's a
research scientist at MIT Media Lab in
the synthetic neurobiology group focused
on advanced
Imaging and interfacing techniques and
you can check out curios links below as
well so check out the work we're gonna
be unpacking a lot of really cool
cutting-edge stuff so let's jump into
this with one of our favorite questions
we like asking we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is your current
take on the state of our world stays a
foul word I in everyday life the most
think I enjoyed our creativity and I
think everybody would enjoy himself a
lot more if we can be creative and
uncover our potentials and creativity so
I imagine our world with ideal world
like ancient Greeks when we were doing
some of week early seven we wore
thinking about world without doing a
bunch of hard work and let's imagine
other robots doing it for us and this is
what I would like to achieve so
everybody can do whatever we want
and be happy and I think this is the
most powerful thing we can do in our
while be happy be creative and get this
kind of you know to reveal our potential
and at the same time I would like to be
creative and revealing potential in the
full harmony with nature yes this is
what I imagine this is my perspective
this is what I would like to achieve and
this is why I also study science and
study and I tried to do research because
I want to understand with nature better
understanding nature better I would
believe it it will allow us to live in
better harmony with it because I am very
concerned you know we grow lots of stuff
going on climate change some and this is
think we students in the same very well
and I think everything in the world is
connected and even distant world
starting from very small atoms up to
entire universe with now people putting
with images of entire like not entire
but as much as the Hubble could image
and if we can scale it up and see okay
this is a harmony we can understand
everything this would be super cool and
and in and why I say again creativity
because in
when we do research creativity's I think
is a driving force creativity interest
is a driving force of our our way when
we trying to understand the world this
is and do research this is what we we
need first of all mr. things yeah yeah
in I love that so much that the full
potential of every single one of these
human animals to be able to be as fully
actualized into the world and to be able
to actually have this this tree that
every single person is a see to have
that have the roots have the right
nutrients so that they can have the best
possible fruits and flowers for the
civilization is so important and I love
that one and and to be able to update
the code of our world to make that
easier more effective to deploy the next
advancements in code for that is so
critical and like you said with nature
in harmony with nature so critical all
right let's go into the journey so your
kid and you're growing up in Belarus
yeah in a small town about 10,000 people
population 10,000 people population yes
see this is a small town and then I want
to know how you got interested in
science you talk about science is such
an important part of your life and of
pushing the edge for our world so how
did you get hooked into science at the
young age so the earliest memory of me
doing experiments what I have right now
it was probably first grade of
elementary school when we found a pieces
of calcium carbide and when you put it
in water salty release acetylene gas
that back when were used to solder pipes
and we were putting kids on fire I
really enjoy it and when I get back home
my brother was seven years older than me
and he was already studying chemistry by
the time when I was in elementary school
I found his books on chemistry and
physics and I was I started
reading didn't understand much I was
very fascinating cooking on the pictures
in books without understanding much of a
text I feels great I really got into it
and this is when I first time
participated in chemistry Olympiad I
started from a chemistry Olympiad nice
and why is your project in the chemistry
Olympiad in Berkman is in a Soviet Union
system but when it was still a kind of
Soviet Union system it was mostly
solving for problems and you compete
with other these are the pupils school
students to get the highest score to go
to the next level and go to the next
lower and I also was very lucky because
my parents were working in industry that
my mom was a dairy factory my dad was at
mechanical factory we had an access to
the lab ah
and I was always oh can you take me to
your work I want to check out your labs
and I was asking people from web can I
take a little bit chemical and I can do
explosions it's calm so I had a small
home lab for all my middle school and
this is how I got involved and it was
getting more and more and more every
year yes so next summer I said ok I
don't want to go play to backyard with
my friends I wanna I want to mix some
chemicals and see what happens yeah
interesting so that's in that's such a
critical part of being young is that
when you get the tools and resources
that you need to be able to explore what
interests you like being able to have
your lab at home and be able to play
with it almost everything although my
parents didn't like it to my gris-gris
no not always created a good smell but I
try to sneak in and do some experiments
and then did
that's interest in chemistry then
continued to when you went to Moscow is
that how yeah so I was a venerable
friend
national chemistry Olympiad and I'll do
a winner
okay silver medal the silver medal there
is no silver
Wow and how old were you then it was 15
Wow good job yeah and I was during foot
training at Moscow State University
before Olympiad I talked to a faculty
where and they say oh if you if you're a
winner
we'll invite you without any exams to
enroll Moscow State University chemistry
department and back when it was my my
dream to enroll School of Chemistry at
Moscow State University because it was
the best school of chemistry back when
in in entire post-soviet space yes ok so
I didn't think about just like that you
get silver medal they accept you in for
for for the chemistry program correct oh
sweet ok
so you make the move to Moscow and you
start studying chemistry and you
continue this process of pushing the
edge of science playing with chemistry
yeah I was happy I got an access to a
bigger lab
with more capital this MOU flask and I
started doing experiments yeah I was
doing organic chemistry what's for meta
organic chemistry actually first and
second year at college but I also very
quickly realize okay this is not very
healthy unfortunately we didn't often
fall over safety rules and I could tell
yeah I I feel like okay I I smell bad
after all AB because we didn't have a
proper ventilation and I decide all
maybe I should work a little bit with
the safer chemicals and this is how I
got a transition into a department of
natural compounds chemistry of natural
compounds okay I decided to work with
DNA RNA and polysaccharides something
with we consist of yes and I said okay
this is gonna be a little bit safer for
my health
yeah interesting so some of the initial
chemical
if you're playing in laps that don't
have good ventilation systems we can end
up inhaling those and that cannot be
healthy so that's very important to have
a very strong lab safety but then that
got you interested in the life sciences
with DNA RNA yeah yeah I could do still
chemistry very advanced chemistry but
with the materials which I could not eat
but we definitely require much less
safety rules yeah and then what were you
doing with DNA RNA pol secre it's what
were you doing oh so back when in in the
department I start working on my diploma
work so my my interest was in regulation
of expression of genes in bacteria we
were trying to understand mechanisms of
how bacteria switch over gene expression
during different conditions during
transition at different conditions some
heat shock or some other negative
environmental influence how it does how
fast and what we can learn about it so
it was pretty fundamental work on gene
regulation interesting so the
environment of bacteria can cause the
gene regulation to change quietly
sometimes quickly differently from
normal and you would measure that out
and vlog it and then direct the people
yes alright interesting and then that
can potentially be used for a lot of our
life sciences today in different ways we
can use the gene regulation and
expression in tons of different ways
potentially for humans and for our world
yeah yeah yeah and this it's like a big
catalog that's unexplored right now and
we have to figure out yeah yeah okay and
then how did from Moscow you go to Bronx
in New York City because that's this is
a big move
yeah transatlantic move yeah how did
that happen
so during how we study gene expression
we use fluorescent proteins because it's
very easy with fearsome protein once you
get expressed in bacteria you can easily
why's bacteria under a microscope and we
had my department had the connection to
the lab at Albert Einstein College of
Medicine but we're looking for a
graduate student to work on the
fluorescent proteins cool so I got an
invitation for grad school and I didn't
think much and say yeah of course I
would like to continue my work in New
York I got invited the platform is but I
remember I had like was six hundred
dollars in my pocket I bought the ticket
I have very small luggage in a flew to
New York I love it huge risk I love it
yeah I I was I decided to risk it exam
and it also was my dream because back
when during my undergrad I was reading
course of papers yeah my favorite papers
and I saw it all this work is done in
the United States and I wanted to see or
is it really so cool I wanna go see
buddies by myself really so cool 90% of
work was done in the United States so I
wanted to to get with experience so I
didn't think much to get tickets and
flew it in 30 days I think it was yeah
really quick okay and then when you get
to Bronx then you're doing cool things
at the Albert Einstein College of
Medicine working on the development of
novel fluorescent proteins for imaging
for in vivo imaging yes yes so teach us
about what this is like so very often in
biology what biologists wanna very often
we say seeing is believing if I see I
believe and in order to see things
inside of ourselves we need to light
them up and in 1978 Osamu Shimomura inve
on a west coast hired bunch of middle
school kids to catch a query Victoria
for him in the bay and bring him to his
small laboratory it was some elaborate
full a section and
extraction of a special pigment which
later on was used to identify GFP green
fluorescent protein Wow
we toyed around Martin Chalfie clone
with cDNA and express it in syllables so
first application for GFP was in
silligans it wasn't a tower of silence
Journal in 1994 and waitron Roger Tsien
used with cDNA to evolve at officially
in a tube in a PCR to evolve all the
spectral diversity from blue to yellow
whoa 2008 it resulted in a Nobel Prize
to three scientists a sham Osamu
Shimomura Rogers Ian and Martin Chalfie
and back when when I joined the grad
school 2007 it was wave of his
development of a new colors new proteins
with a new properties it was extremely
popular and extremely useful for
biologists to put different to highlight
different structures different molecules
inside of our cells so we can observe it
in real time under a microscope so when
now we can see the things and now we can
believe it yeah but we decided to scale
it up and we decided okay we don't want
to do it in a Cell in a petri dish we
want to do it in a cell in a whole body
in a living organism okay quick so we
are taking fluorescent proteins from
fish it's jelly fish and corals mostly
it's jelly fish and corals okay 90% of
them coming from this tool okay
hydras or and anthozoa Hydra surgery
fish it's gone to hydras orcas corals
from anthozoa
and so they can express fluorescence
fluorescent protein so they can express
fluorescence we have a fluorescent
protein expression all right okay so we
took that fluorescent protein expression
and we were able to figure out how to
express from
luta yellow yes yes so we were able to
fine-tune this proteins to emit the
light in this range emit the light in
this range and then then you took that
ability and took it in vivo into the
cell and were able to say I want to take
the mitochondria for example anything we
could do anything and then you could
look under the microscope and see the
fluorescent the mitochondrial lit under
the cell absolutely yes that's beautiful
yes yes and we could do it in many
different colors we can result many
different colors and you can do
multiplexing do multiple things
simultaneously okay because you could do
blue for specific ribosome and yellow
for the mitochondria or and then Wow
yeah that's so cool and but when we
decided to do it in vivo how does it
know wait how does how do you how does
it know to go to the ribosome or the
mitochondria how do you write so nature
is very smart everything is very very
regulated nature falls very well Falls
paroles and we can understand these
rules and use them for our purposes to
study and in order to send the protein
to mitochondria we append it with a
small sequence once with sequences in a
Cell floating in cytoplasm is get
recognized by cellular machinery and get
exported to mitochondria it's like
signaling sequences okay so you add a
signaling sequence to the protein and
then and then the cell will say okay
let's go to this area in the depending
on this signal that you add to the
protein it will tell it to go to a
different part of the cell so people
figure out many different ways to go at
different different structures signal
single molecules or some other subsolar
structures
okay okay cool cool all right so then
that going to from in vivo you started
saying that you
wanted to take that into human or at
least animal yes to two whole organisms
yes and what's happening with the whole
organisms that the shorter wavelengths
of the light the harder is to catch its
emission so if you ever put your hand on
on a lamp mm-hmm you see you so red yes
did you yes yes yes so because of blood
you have in your hand yes yes but
because the hand is like a filter it's
filter all the wavelengths except the
red one so red gets through and you see
interest is your red so and what does it
mean it means that the red color red
white is the light with the biggest
penetration long enough wavelength to be
able to get through our correct cells
yes our teach our tissue it yes
interesting but blue and purple cannot
no yellow green no blue so we have much
shorter distance of a absorb more and we
scatter more it's a it's a factor of two
its scattering and absorption
interesting okay so and as a result the
my major goal was to make person
proteins with a long enough emission
spectrum so we can do whole body imaging
in of small animals like back when I was
working with Mouse mostly and how did
that go
it wasn't very it didn't work very well
in the beginning so we were trying to
push GFP and other proteins which we
found in corals to a spectrum up to 700
nanometers so this is an edge of what
our eye can see beyond 700 is getting a
spectrum for I get inquiry difficult to
recognize and again we got a hint from
Roger Tsien in 2009 he publishes he
published paper in science on using
bacteria phytochromes this time we found
different type of
organism in a soil bacteria we use red
light to regulate her cycle and why I
was surprised why red white in the soil
back there because this is one little
white which can get through a door with
bacteria living in to get them activated
in this proteins called bacteria
phytochromes and i was surprised by
pretty abundant and this protein had a
completely different chromophore that
could bring us beyond 700 nanometers I
think most redshifted thurston protein
right now from dr. FATA Chrome's is 720
nanometers so you need night-vision
goggles if you want to see it with your
eyes so this is this is my vs. Cowie the
goal was can we push it to in vivo we
tried and failed with the fluorescent
protein from jelly fish and corals and
we were able to make it to work in
corals or in from bacteria phytochromes
from bacteria okay and then how did you
then go from the Albert Einstein College
of Medicine to Cambridge the major
application that I was working for his
fearsome proteins when we were imaging
was cancer research mm-hmm and I think
it's very important research and can be
very very impactful potentially lighting
up the cancer cells to see how they get
through a tumor to the bloodstream and
from bloodstream to the lungs so we our
goal was to trace metastases over cells
because why people dying from cancer
it's most often because of our long
lungs getting clamped with lots of cells
from a tumor from metastases we're
getting into long start propagating and
people suffocating
so this was the major
I think if we could stop metastasis it
means we can at least slow down the
cancer in our people and our goal was to
develop methods which could allow us to
visualize how a single cells from a
tumour site going to the lungs in the
whole body in this case using Chris kind
of model organism we'll be able to treat
we will be able to find treatment as
fast as possible we for example given
some drugs to a mouse and see if we can
stop or reduce the speed of his
metastases and during my PhD work I was
reading a lot about other types of white
sensitive molecules and one molecule
would fascinated me a lot was
channelrhodopsin-2 it was published in
2005 in Journal neuroscience and it was
shown that expression of
channelrhodopsin-2 molecules wild-type
molecule from another algae its units or
algae can allow us to activate neuronal
activity with a single spike precision
whoa and this gave us enormous enormous
application for neuroscience in order to
for example to crack with neuronal quote
it would be very very useful using quiet
to either activate or science near an
activity this is something which was
predicted or not predicted but something
which was anticipated in 1978 when I
think Crick said one of the people who
got nobel prize for DNA structure he
said it will be very very useful to have
a tool that would allow us optical
control neuronal activity in vivo and
this is happened in 2005 I was extremely
fascinated by channelrhodopsin and the
first author on this paper at the same
day when I was reading about
channelrhodopsin was in our
[Music]
at Albert Einstein College of Medicine
giving a lecture it was that boiler and
I attended his lecture and I decided
okay missus he's doing great research I
wanna be part of his team advancing new
optogenetic tools for Neuroscience I
melt him right away
I even remember with first time less
than five minutes
he should be back oh do you want to stop
by my web and we can chat about it more
and I said of course we taking a car and
driving up to Cambridge when I met him I
proposed him some research and he told
me why don't you come over and work for
me I said no problem and yeah and and
that gave me a postdoc position right
away I was very very happy I joined it
in 2013
Wow Wow okay but then from you that was
2006 was the paper and 2013 is when he
joined the team yeah so it was a several
years not so many people believed in
optogenetics and it was in 2015 it was
ten years of optogenetics and I think
nature science published a small article
about quotes of different people and you
can see what 50% of people think oh it's
cool but it's not going to go anywhere
you know and but 2010 it was methods
over a year I think 2010 so it was very
very rapid and I was already on the way
when people realized okay this is this
is gonna be very huge by the time it was
very very huge yes okay and I wanted to
be part of it I wanted to make it even
bigger interesting so yeah optogenetics
for neuromodulation for either exciting
or inhibiting neuronal correct cells all
right now I'm interested to know what
you came in with the proposals you said
that yeah it was like yes come on yeah
join the synthetic neurobiology group
the proposal very when I talk to it for
first time I very quickly understood
he's a very big thinker he thinks very
very big and I decided in order to
impress him I also gotta think big
I was very interesting in it was also a
time of a singularity talks people who
talk about singularity and I was
thinking about cyborgs which would
combine artificial some part of probably
silicon hardware and carbon hardware our
our brains and we knew that it's very
difficult to combine with two together
materials especially if we in short for
electrodes into the brain we get immune
response cells dies around well it
doesn't stay for too long but if we
interact with silicon life and carbon
life interact through the light it's
much safer and what can give us the
ability to interact this light is a
optogenetic tools yeah we can boss
transmit information to a neurons excite
them when he meets them at the same time
you can read the out with information by
white ok let me give a quick example for
maybe something that's very relatable so
something that we can consider even
optogenetic is how we take in visual
information all the time so well so as
we take in stimuli of light reflecting
off of chairs and tables and all that
stuff we are modulating neurons and so
that is up to genetic in that sense and
molecules in our retina rhodopsins
responsible for interacting with the
light we're very similar to optogenetic
tools with we currently using yes it's a
type one rhodopsins
from algae because of my microbial
opsins for algae and bacteria and fungi
and we have type two rhodopsins is one
of his example in our in our eyes yes
rhodopsin rhodopsin
interesting so it's very similar
mechanism where get excited in our eye
and we generating certain signals and
you wanted to make it easier for silicon
to interface with the carbon in us
through optogenetic so would this be
somehow through the optical modulating
light and then that modulating neurons
no but when I was thinking that we do
have to deliver options into our neurons
and get some optical some kind of
illumination devices and camera around
our skull for humans which is how I
imagine so we we can talk through
through a skull using quiet we excite
and we collect all right Rosco although
but we will have to genetically modify
our neurons go and express something so
this is something FDA still does not
work can you go from outside the cranium
can with light so red light can go
through interesting not far but it kept
for miles we were able to do it with red
light red white so Wow we now can do
non-invasive for example calcium imaging
using mean for red sensors yeah through
the skin and through the skull
interesting although resolution is
dropping it's not a single-cell
resolution but we can do non-invasive
yeah not single self-adhesive due to a
too much scattering but interesting Wow
so this is my idea and that said this is
a great idea it's not going to work
right now this is not the right time for
this idea but common and can work with
us okay so the now is kind of your 2013
getting in top to genetics studying that
also studying expansion microscopy being
able to expand the tissue actually but
then I just join the group ex-special
microscopy
didn't exist better what was that 2006
15 so it was published at end of 2014
okay when I joined the lab Paul and Faye
and I think he's shunned they already
had an idea or we want to make things
bigger in order to get a better
resolution of a small features inside
but but when it I think even with tormak
suspension mccroskey wasn't yet invented
yeah
but yeah it was very very rapid
development because we very quickly
figure out how to expand where
biological samples isotropically
preserving some labels but we could see
under microscope you preserve the shape
of the tissue
yes yeah that's so critical and then be
able to do things like have the
fluorescent proteins as well yes yeah so
and this is where my expertise helped a
little bit when we brainstorm with Faye
he told me oh I can anchor proteins
right now into a gel and I told him we
need to do to the GFP because GFP is
robust enough to survive expansion
digestion expansion and I remember I
gave him samples with the fluorescent
proteins in cells he explained it in his
workouts beautifully from a first
attempt we never repeat this experiment
it's work out and we say okay we gotta
we gotta hurry up and publish it here
ahaha so cool so that that is actually a
big testament to when you put together
the multidisciplinary thinking where you
come with expertise of fluorescent
proteins with the expertise of pushing
expansion microscopy and you're like hey
add this yeah that's really cool it was
a unique environment it's still a very
unique environment and so many different
people was very different background and
expert
is working together and talking on a
daily basis this is were brainstorming
happening on yeah all the time and this
is when we're getting new ideas new
crazy ideas to try out people I enjoy
I'm doing it a lot I think this is very
unique this is very it's super unique
the two words that I think have been a
major part of my understanding of
synthetic neurobiology most recently has
been optogenetics and expansion control
across capilla and I think I've been
expansion microscopy recently I start to
take over even more yeah I know
I've been participating in several
conferences and people when we talk to
me I am saying oh I'm in ed Boyden lab
and he's all expression microscopy lab
yeah that's so great and all right and
now I want you to take us into these
novel tools and methods for neural
imaging and interfacing the ones that
especially like you know the ones that
you worked on you said about four years
of the time from 2013 2019 six years but
you worked for years specifically on
optical voltage sensors correct yes so
yes who teaches about what that that is
a robotic multidimensional directed
evolution approach applied to
fluorescent voltage reporters so when I
proposed this idea of interfacing brain
with the machine using collide we had
perfect optogenetic tools so we can
communicate information to the neurons
but back then we didn't have any tools
that can communicate information from
the neurons back to the machine this is
one of the reason why I said ok this is
not the right time we don't still have
all tool set for for this kind of
approach and we were missing the
molecule but would convert to light but
would convert voltage over neurons back
to the light so
now optogenetic convert to light into a
voltage we need something voltage back
into the light yes and that's proposed
oh how how about you you develop a
voltage sensor but can be compatible
with optogenetic control and can report
voltage with a sub threshold precision
at the biologically relevant time scale
because neurons have fastest cells in
terms of changing for membrane potential
this is how we communicate like make
millisecond even microseconds yeah we're
sending very short electrical pulses
along the neurons along with axons and
this is how we communicate so if we want
to understand when neurons we need to
record action potentials we need to
record the voltage across the plasma
membrane so we're talking right now
while you and I are talking we have
billions of neurons that are firing then
talking to and talking to each other
although we don't see it we don't see it
yeah is there early feel it even you
have to really you have to really try
and tap into it same as we look at with
wives we know where is electricity going
on where but we don't see it so we need
some sort of molecule but with sensor
voltage and convert it into the light a
molecule it's a molecule yes it's a
protein it's a protein nature it's a
protein that can sense voltage across
the plasma membrane
convert the chromophore in a way but
it's going to be fluorescent so every
time neuron spikes receive increase of
light flash in
on-chip of our camera and then did you
do that in vivo first so we didn't have
a small echo it was just imaging
imagination at first yeah yeah although
we knew some of possible molecular
mechanisms how to convert voltage into
the light we didn't have a molecule that
would work with
neurons and and we didn't know how to
make it and what we decided to do we
decided to call but we just create very
very large library very diverse so I
broke different different genes using
special one special unique molecular
cured obscene arc or ellipse in three it
also was this Moloch was discovered by
at first time we mutated and will try to
screen it and see if any of the mutants
from this molecule can sense voltage
inside the cells library was up to ten
millions up ten millions individual
cones screening of each cell manually
takes several minutes so it means I
wouldn't be able to finish probably with
screen covers library till nowadays if I
start doing it manually and was saying
oh how about we just make robot to do it
for us and this is how we end up
designing a special robot which can
image very large population of a cells
automatically pick the best cells
expressing voltage sensing molecule and
selected using a micropipette and
everything in in automated mode in fully
automated mode I remember with this day
when I click start it took me about two
years to make it to happen but once it's
everything was set we click start button
robot did it for us for two hours by
always drinking coffee that when do is
process I take we're tube with a few
cells like this from a plate I clone the
genes and one of them was the archon
voltage sensor which we currently using
for voltage imaging in vivo Wow two
years to set it up and when two hours to
find it zero
but okay two and plus two hours to
quality whoa okay so I'm as a as a you
know an advanced monkey I'm trying to
understand this and okay so there's your
really you want to be able to have a way
to sense the voltage yeah okay and the
the modulation you want to be able to
sense the modulation both of these
voltage sensors that can sense a very
very small amount of voltage correct
okay and then you also need the robotic
assistance to be able to see that that
action so robotic assistance we need to
develop this molecule to develop so we
back when we knew what our current
obscene was dimly fluorescent and it
it's pure essence was modulated by
voltage it was done by the atom coin and
I think we published with work in 2011
however was molecule had many
disadvantages and didn't work in neurons
we wanted to make it in to work in
neurons and we use this evolution it's
same method but nature using what nature
does it's creating genetic diversity
when applying selective pressure see who
survived parent survived we give a next
breed and process repeats again multiple
iteration so we do something similar in
in the tube and much much faster
we took the molecule is our collapsing
molecule but didn't work in neurons
it wasn't very bright did not go ice to
the membrane but it was voltage
sensitive and it was fluorescent and
what we were able to do we were able to
enhance all these properties by mutating
randomly mutating some positions
and but in order to have to be mutate in
order to understand what mutant art with
ten millions yes unique mutants are the
right one you need a robot yes we do it
for us
automatically and the mutants did what
so mutants were expressed in mammalian
cells and we were able to assess the
localization so view
so first property what we assessed it to
make sure that protein is localized to
the membrane because the electric field
in a Cell only exists across the
membrane
once you want more than one and a meter
away from the membrane there is no more
electric field its Debye reduces its
decay and very very quick so first we
need to make sure the molecules are not
on the membrane expressed well second we
want to make sure that molecule shows
sufficient level of fluorescence in
order for us to image and third we need
to confirm what during what changes
during for modulation of voltage across
the plasma membrane it changed for
fluorescence so we had to optimize three
properties in four ten thousand or ten
million of independent independent
clones and the ones that were the
successful mutants were the ones again
that did yes we can repeat it several
times exhibit did it twice yes okay and
that those those successful mutants that
you took and that could repeat they did
what again they were able to sense the
word
well localizing to the membrane sense
for voltage and were bright enough for
us to image it using optical using
fluorescent microscope ok so what we're
making is better and better than but
yeah so break it down one more time we
could go past the membrane that uh yes
yes so it can get incorporated into the
membrane okay
because only voltage exists across
remember yes okay
second it possess some fluorescence yes
so we can image and
the fluorescence depends on a voltage
across the plasma membrane the higher
voltage for high of your essence okay
okay okay
just barely understanding it just barely
tiny I can tell you what how it looks
like under microscope you see when
neuron with blinking yeah you shine with
certain light and you image where
fluorescence and it's blinking yeah and
we know what each blink responds to
action potential yes this is the main
idea yeah but to make this molecule we
need to do the 10 million mutations and
try and find the neurons that could
through when you do opto genetics it
will show its action potential yes okay
still child understanding I love it I
love it it's because it takes years of
really diving in to be able to get it
but okay so then the now teach us about
what with that technology what can you
do with that you know we can read minds
how yes this is if we go very far this
is the big goal so miss miss technology
we were able to image activity over
neurons in behaving animals with a
single cell single spied precision so in
we believe that every neuron is
important so we're on several classical
papers showing that even driving of one
neuron in the brain can change the
status of animal it can go from
aggression to feel the point fly affect
but by changing just activity of wine I
think it was yeah classical paper in
published in nature yes so it means
every neuron in our brain can be very
very important in order to understand
the brain
it means that in order to understand the
brain we need to image we need to
understand how every cell spikes and how
we connect it to each other so you can
take the mutated neuron that can be that
can be stimulated and read up to
genetically that you can then take that
and potentially implant that neuron what
we do we inject viruses into a mouse
brain you inject a virus I Dennis
recombinant and then associated viruses
yes with viruses gets inside the winner
ons and make with neurons express our
molecules channelrhodopsin and voltage
sensor and now with labels was drive and
see with neurons so we were able boss
activate when your own activity and see
heard you did both so then you read what
the mouse what the neural activity so
what we did next we put anymore on a
ball and so no first we injected virus
virus to express our voltage sensor in
neurons then we put a small window on a
skull to gain an optical access to the
neurons we put this anymore under my
microscope image when neurons it was
actually in subcortical brain region
called stratum it's a region responsible
for its many functions but one most
prominent is locomotion so we gain an
optical axis to stratum we sober cells
expressing voltage sensor we make
anymore run on the ball and while it's
running on the ball we recorded the
speed at what animal was running it was
volunteering volunteering motion and the
image winner ons with a single spike
precision after the imaging was done we
related with speed to activity of
neurons and we were able to find that 30
percent of a cells spike faster when
animal is moving
and about 10% of ourselves were spies
spike insu or when anymore wasn't moving
it give us an ability when in future for
example we image only neurons and we
don't know what any mo is doing based on
Parton's of neuron activity we can say
animal was sitting or running yeah so
this is kind of a starting point
yes reading minds okay okay so then just
from neural activity you could tell if
an animal's running or so yeah in
principle yeah so this is what people
right now trying to do in neuroscience
we're obtaining very big very large data
sets one of them people doing for zebra
fish when we observing zebra fish
recording activity of zebra fish during
swimming and then using quiz data if you
have input activity over neurons you can
tell was animal or zebra fish swimming
or not swimming or doing something else
and you can determine that with a very
high degree of accuracy if it's swimming
or not dancing and probably even predict
the speed and direction so that's cool
too it's a next level yeah so but I
would say it's a certain extent it's
kind of rethink mine yeah so it's kind
of yeah but of course we we don't use it
for breeding point we're trying to use
it to understand how the brain works how
the brain works because how do you when
can you tell from neural activity if I
see the color red or blue can you
determine from the neural activity if
I'm happy or sad so that yes absolutely
so then this is where we want
potentially yes of only one problem in
its so in a mouse brain it's coming ten
millions or hundred millions of neurons
we were able to image all the 30 up to
30 so you can understand the scale but
13 neurons were able to we were able to
tell if it's running or if it's yes
stopped yes so we were able on this
scale already because it's something
very
so many neurons involved in the same
question if I was wearing an EEG and I
was you know either running on a
treadmill or walking or imaging with
you're running or imagining that I'm
running on a treadmill could you tell
the difference in the door for eg I
don't know probably from EEG yes because
of a solution but we have neurosurgeon
yes we can you can say but neuronal
activity with the single cell on singles
by precision gives much much better
predictive yeah because you can run and
doing something else and you may not be
able to go okay so we would like to do
complete and aesthetic everything
everything but often we cannot track
some very small details of any more is
doing so in running is very it's a Santa
cager going on with anymore lots of
neurons involved into this locomotion so
what's why we were able and actually
that's why we selected this task because
we knew this is something but we will be
able to find people knew about this kind
of fact but we were able to show it to
using optical imaging mmhmm yeah and so
the also curious how long the by imp
using the virus for the implanting the
voltage sensors how long did them mice
live afterwards we were able to image
animals up to half a year interesting
half a year about yeah six months every
few weeks we were able to image yeah our
best animals yeah survive oh yeah we had
actually we had to perfuse him I think
we could even image from wonder we had
to perfuse them to show what histology
photo paper this was the end point
because the reviewers asked us all can
you please show us histology so we
really know what are we imaging and so
then would there be a
of consequence potentially if we were to
implant ourselves with the virus so this
is what we still need to understand but
Eevee is one of the safest viruses but
don't say facade versus I think the
voltage sensor this is another thing I
mean this is something which we need to
study more and assess more as you said
those molecules get into the neurons
yeah a membrane the membrane yeah so but
on a positive note on a positive note I
think two years ago over a year ago FDA
approved gene therapy based on options
for eyes for blindness I think it's
about several hundred thousand dollar
injection into vibe but carry a V but in
codes for options so people can restore
some vision I don't know how many people
use it but it this is something that was
approved by FDA and I didn't think ten
years ago I couldn't even imagine it
would be possible so we don't know
what's gonna be in another ten years and
how we can advance our our knowledge and
our technology in ten more years here
where would the technology that you've
been teaching us where would this take
us translationally in the next couple of
decades if we were to be able to unlock
so my biggest culprit now that this
technology may allow us to perform new
type of experiments but were not
possible before
to find better understanding cover most
of the neurological disease we are going
through so it's very interesting if you
look if we look back on humankind and we
were one of the most dramatic change
what's happened is lifespan of humans
increased almost twice in the past
jury right we will link about 40 years
now we are going up to 80 years and what
we discovered that the longer we live
the more diseases we get different types
of diseases and one of bad disease was
happening to us it's a neurological
disease especially after each 6c but
probability increases very very quick
and maybe we are getting a little bit a
longer lifespan but not always quality
of life improving so fast
and I make my biggest goal and this is
what I would like to see happening using
my technology but we will be able to
understand the underlying mechanisms for
the neurological disease but we are
getting right now and using this
knowledge try to solve how we can
treatment because right now there is no
basically there is no any treatment for
neural disorders and the virus am we
work only partially with lots of lots of
side effects and how would your
technology enable us to tackle the so we
one of the interesting thing with we
brainstorm a lot and I think we already
we were working a little bit right now
in 2016 the hits I discovered we
published paper in Nature in 2016 but if
we Flickr for record slide in towards
guy reminds for several days one hour
per day we have an ovoid block clearing
it's just magically amyloid plaque yeah
very very so a reduction up to 50
percent forty to fifty percent and very
often I know it blocks associated with
and Schuyler disease and it's just
flashing as in
what if you are forced to look at yeah
so animal sign the cage and there are
LEDs but it's flickering at forty codes
for an hour per day for an hour per day
yeah
I wonder if that translates to humans
however do we are we doing any trial yes
so I think we got permission to do it on
humans right now so in a recent paper
published in cell we even went a little
bit further and we showed it's not only
know it works clearing but also reserves
restoration of some cognitive abilities
this is but more important which
cognitive abilities reversal so I think
it major it's memo memory so anymore I
think animals were doing better in the
maze so when we have to get to find
about exit from the makers and animals
is a treatment who are able to figure
out it fast because we remember I may
remember it's better and but nobody
understands why and how it's happening
nobody knows where is the treatment is
like a very big black box nobody knows
why it's happening and what's our best
guess I don't know
and very some sort of synchronization
what I believe and what I saw from some
preliminary lot I think there is some
synchronization of the cells and the
synchronization of a cells activate
certain mechanisms in the brain but
probably activate glia microglia to come
and clean up but I know it works
clearing cup of vitamin blocks can
restore of a better connection between
neurons
gulia is doing the my plaque clear yes
some interesting real cells are doing
the cleanup this is what do you think
this is what I I think this is the case
some studies was showing in vivo studies
here and continue and then and then the
clearing of the my plaque enables the
the circuitry to continue its original
way of retaining really good
connectivity and memory this is what I
got a father sighs this or anything yeah
okay okay so then that's one of the
awesome uses yes and I believe it
if we will be able to see how the
neurons synchronized and how we activity
the Croatian of activity for example
during for occurs flickering and without
for records flickering that's kind of
models of mouse we will get a better
idea how it works on a functional on a
single mode on a single cell level and
we will get some clues on how we can
induce it how we make it stronger or
maybe it's too much of flickering is
gonna be also bad
something yeah so this is where my
biggest coca cotton coming from for for
this technology so our major goal right
now is to spread this technology to
neuroscience community and everybody to
use it to answer Reverb biological
questions this grandeur is just one
example but also Parkinson yes epilepsy
and so on so forth yes yes which are
tens of millions of people around the
world yes yeah yeah okay and then how
does the you know that was on an
optogenetics level of using that
technology but what about the optical
voltage sensors applied do they apply in
the same how do you how does your virus
yes yes it's a very similar molecules
actually voltage sensor with we use ink
right now was made out of optogenetic
tools we we made them to work in the
reviewers so the sensor what we found
was built on optogenetic tools you
shanbo line a changeable voltage but we
make it to work in the reviewers what it
changes in the chamber light voltage
changes and then you shine yes and it
means that the same principle on how to
deliver how to use it in vivo same as
for the genetics also yes
okay okay because Leroy sighs work is
without yes it was an invasive fish
absolutely it was piracy Ino virus we
were flickering fry
yes non-invasive but your virus and yeah
so alters yeah what we would like to do
you would like using voltage sensors we
would like to see what's going on in the
brain when the flickering yeah yeah
what's going on now you want to add your
optical voltage sensors to those
experiments we want to combine it and
then see what happens in those action
potentials of the specific let's say 30
neurons again that you for example for
example although we I believe we're
gonna push it to 300 we're working to
push it to a huge on the order of
magnitude crisis but yes I mean that
what would you hire a size that you see
my impression from very preliminary
results what I saw I think we will get a
synchronization of a cells and most
likely with synchronization of a support
level and probably some higher Croatian
coherence of single spikes this what I
think we're gonna see but we need to
this is just my coherence and
synchronization yes so angle spikes so
we will get suppress show the solution
we will get more coherent and single
spike who will happen at the same timing
for multiple or same timing for motor
neurons okay interesting
Wow and then that could be one of the
remedies for neurological disorders is
yeah for example you want to see yes how
fast and why it's happening and what
kind of other other mechanisms triggered
by the synchronization yeah our our
brain is very synchronized you know
many many brainwaves so-called brain
waves from alpha to gamma yeah so at
every brain state characterized by
different frequency when we sleep it's
one frequency when we think it's
different frequency when we walk and so
and so forth so synchronization and
sample synchronizations
of neurons is pretty important for Oh
Brenda because it's potentially that up
to genetics of that of that light that
is being shined to clear up the amyloid
plaque buildup could be a
synchronization of a specific one of
these may be an alpha or it's actually a
gamma
it's a gamma it's a gamma yeah yes again
interesting so then we know that it's
potential that's the hypothesis that
it's a gamma synchronization that causes
the cleanup of the my plank and that in
kind of the in a sense it's the
restoration to homeostasis from a
deteriorated state back probably
potentially yeah it's very exciting the
work is mind-blowing I love it yeah so
this is my biggest hope and but I would
like to spread the tool and I would be
very happy with molecule my technologies
technologies I'm developing will help in
many of its biological tissues yeah and
so the optical voltage sensors help us
be able to measure things like that
synchronization correctly yes okay this
is what we showed in 32 potentially up
to hopefully 300 and around soon versus
at an EEG at a at a correct you can't
actually get down to a single neuron
level yeah and this company it's we're
getting qualitatively different
information from from EEG and from
voltage sensors and in because those
voltage sensors have the fluorescent
protein you can view that the
potentials we can even tell in the
dendrites from what dendrite it comes to
a soma what we can resolve especially
from which dendrite even become we can
see it where it comes from yes where it
comes from because imaging happening on
kilohertz frequencies
q occurs frequencies yeah and yeah if we
can even say see how it's originating in
the dendrites propagate was soma gets it
action potential yeah
so people before were able to do this
kind of experiments only in cultured
primary cultured cells and which is not
relevant because culture results we
don't do anything we're not connected to
a function to behavioral and when we can
connect it to the big hero in view of
visas were of fun stuff starts yeah yeah
okay so then what does to code ok so
then that's back to the whole running
versus walking okay or potentially the
happy or sad okay okay it seems like if
we were in a gamma synchrony that it
would be a state of of really wait of
bliss or transcendence or so no so not
necessarily okay usually when we focused
when we think this is where we see gamma
gamma benefits but that's like really
deep flow states right yeah so and also
we have multiple different brain regions
and different brain regions prefer
different events at different time yes
okay okay this is another thing again it
can be a mixture of multiple it can be
alpha over but on gamma yeah but what we
say we also talked about power of each
band in isolation okay that works
yeah more for another time absolutely
yeah there's so much to so unpack about
what you're doing it's all so crazy that
you are you know you want to take these
tool
and you want to spread them around the
world and we want to get them in the
hands of you know 12 16 18 19 year-olds
get them in the hands of young people to
be able to go with their own creative
thinking and bill oh yeah but at the
same time you're leaving the Cambridge
area and you're planning to go to
Westlake University in China on a
10-year track to be an assistant
professor in the School of Life Sciences
in Hangzhou yeah yeah I decided to
accept an offer from Westlake in New
York City
starting sometimes way through this year
because it's given me a great
opportunity to pursue my dreams on my
roll I think I feel very very grateful
to add for this six years with him where
I mature as a scientist now I feel much
more confident going and doing my
science but science on my own and I -
except for because it gives me a great
opportunity to pursue his dreams in in
science because we basically given the
freedom you do whatever you want as one
because it's impactful and this is my
dream I want to do whatever I want
maybe tomorrow it would change my wife
completely or do something else as long
as it's impactful yeah so yeah I will be
moving to China shortly it wasn't maybe
always a very simple decision and choice
for me yeah but I just want to choose my
dream I want to share my dream and
there's no way to chase it near the
other cluster of people in Cambridge
unfortunately I couldn't get any offers
all matching covers from UNITA
yeah for from United States and I would
like to stay in academia so this is my
dream this is nothing but I would like
to be in academia because I believe
academia it's very unique
again unique place would give you
complete freedom of your creativity yes
yes this is when you can change what are
we going to be doing in one day I've
been working in industry and it's very
different philosophy and Industry
approach and I can tell this is not
something which fits me hundred-percent
yes yes maybe there are different
benefits were on the side of salaries
and so on so forth but I for me it's
more important to have this but I can
uncursed we discussed in the beginning
can cover my potential in this kind of
creativity I will give it in curiosity
yes I would
yeah with the resources I would figure
out how to keep you in the Cambridge
area yeah yeah yeah because you are a
very eloquent communicator and a great
scientist and so I think it's very
important to keep you around and be able
to help so I think nowadays science is a
nice shoe and I think science should be
very international because when I
develop something when I create
something I would like it to be open to
anybody yes to everybody anywhere and no
matter what you do no matter where you
live and no matter how you think I want
it if you wanna I want it to be freely
accessible to everyone and the ideas and
other like data I want it to be totally
open to public
yeah the open notebook science is a very
important part of being able to push the
edge of knowledge together as a society
more freely and get the technologies
down to the young people to be able to
play with and use the tools rather than
keeping it closed off for monitor yeah
technology shapes our civilization the
faster we can apply with technology
where more people can use it the better
I think the more positive changes we can
see yeah yeah yeah yeah is so it's tough
because you know it's like a you know
you your wife is also Chinese which
makes this transition a little bit
easier yeah I called will get more
support than this yeah yeah I'm this end
and it's a beautiful facility we were
looking
a little bit before we started in and
and it's good that you'll be in the
School of Life Sciences you'll be
pursuing you know you'll be teaching
other people around the world you'll be
learning about the Chinese culture more
and hopefully we can work on as we say
being this bridge you know I can look at
this very positively - I can say it's a
very good thing that you're going
because now this one of the missions
that I say is that I want to help be a
bridge between the United States and
China I want to help really foster a
bridge to that like open notebook
science that collaboration because I
think that if the United States and
China work together I think we can help
make sure the rest of the world we don't
have any we can mitigate the existential
risks if we work together so maybe we
can do cool things like go out to West
Lake potentially and it'll be great then
interview stronger when we are together
there were much stronger together and I
believe there are many great people in
West Lake who you would like to talk to
definitely yeah correct yeah and that's
such a beautiful a part of the world you
know just very close to Shanghai right
there on Pacific Ocean there's so much
to explore so many brilliant people in
China that are pushing the edge yeah I I
I feel like a trip we've mentioned this
so many times a trip to China to
interview some of the world leading
scientists would it be so important to
do so I'm really looking forward to that
and also think about that on the channel
being able to have a series of 30
interviews with not white you know
people people from Asia from China
specifically it's very important because
then we understand that it doesn't
matter if it's black white purple brown
doesn't matter I believe when we working
together in a very diverse community
this is for the most part of things
happening
I think our creativity the synergy of is
creativity when we're diverse group with
from different backgrounds working
together yeah yeah because then you
realize what someone from from the
eastern civilizations is thinking about
what a Western organ
is a ssin is trying to do and you get
maybe they can actually better the idea
maybe someone from the West can better
one of the ideas from the East so
there's ways to like collaborate on this
maybe someone fresh from a philosophy in
Africa or from Latin America can come in
and give you some profound insight into
your academia or your industry where
your governmental structures and so I
completely agree that it's a very
beautiful thing to be able to work that
way but also a meritocracy at the same
time it's an interesting conversational
point okay just to wrap a couple quick
things this will I found very
interesting we've now interviewed I
believe you know a breda gray Robert
Raja me on there's a couple other people
that don't have cell phones all right
yeah so I we've we now know a decent
amount of scientists that choose to not
have cell phones because they believe
it's destroyer of personal solitude of
focus so what is the reason why you you
choose to not have a cell phone so for
me first of all it's a distraction
distraction if I have a cell phone it
can be destruction when it's ringing or
if it's in my pocket I will be sometimes
unintentionally for example pull akin
and staring at it for no reason so my
observation and it's also some sort of a
protest to to what I see outside so when
I take in a train what I do on a train I
count people on a train who using cell
phones versus call not using cell phones
and tell us the numbers so eighty
percent in Cambridge on a red line I'm
taking with grade one most of time using
a cell phone but what do you do we still
get it like this yeah and I feel
sometimes this is a crazy number this is
a very big number and I
I am afraid one day people who were
goggles all the time we're not gonna see
people around and I think cell phones
were useful but we're also destroying
some of our like what who we really are
because communication I prefer
communication
dorsen meet you I prefer communication
tours and visas I think it's very
different experience so this is another
thing when I don't have a cell phone and
people want to talk to me we all come
and talk to me in tour sense
so promoting is communication in Torsten
so and on a relevant note observation
for example I've been in Tokyo just
recently taking training Tokyo and I
also was counting people using a cell
phone where and it was less no more than
10% on the Tokyo subway system
the reason percent versus that's 80%
yeah Japanese for some reason this is my
observation we don't we we don't use
cell phone on a train and we don't talk
on a cell phone on a train and then a
few weeks later I was in China in
Chinese very different situation
yeah without cell phone you won't be
able to do anything there is a street
food I believe people selling a food
with we just cook at home a couple of
minutes ago
you won't be able to buy a food on the
streets because it's not only payer we
yeah so you scan a QR code and we give
you a food nobody used cash when they
pull all the cash but they were looking
what is it is cash weird yes that you're
just scanning your QR QR code retaken
taxi you'd be pranking us in the story
planned in a restaurant with fun so it's
fun in China integrated in daily life
much more than here and this is another
my fear okay I don't have to use a cell
phone if I go over because I won't be
able to survivor this is I will I go be
pushed to extreme and without cell phone
I won't be able to function well where
you could do something like only
download the payment so yeah and then
only take it with you when you leave the
campus yeah so that good yeah because
then if you're spending your time on the
campus I know wow so it's almost as
though were some of the civil
is forcing you to have the device in
order to interact with people yes and I
also know what I have been I who it may
be it's not very good but I also try to
see what people do in Converse cell
phones during when we taking training oh
yeah I do too when I was when we were in
the there was a Venetian Plaza and there
was a big musical group playing young
girls on their phones and the
instrumentalists right in front of them
but there right there on their phones
and I look and there you know doing that
some game were there you know and just
about 50% of people playing game from my
observation 50% was games
swank Basel so some sorts of games when
you have to do something yes yes yes
with my generation some cases when
people just sliding screams back and
forth so and I'm when I'm walking I am
afraid but ok I'm afraid but I will be
doing keep I kept of one I will be doing
something similar and I think it's very
bad this way this is another mic and you
have people like me that see what you
see and then I just went and deleted all
of my social media apps I turned off all
of my notifications my phone is always
on silent so it's just just call email
text and like maps and uber and stuff
like that right and nothing practical
but even the practicality even that the
notifications are off the phone is
always on silent so I have to go with my
own instinct to go and open the messages
to go look but not me getting sucked
into to go yeah so versus one of I think
two years ago International Health
Organisation classified game dependence
depends on from video games as a
disorder we put it in in a list of
official
others and we also saying that when
people check in phones were often well
off 150 times a day yeah yeah so this is
also by saying this is already out of a
normal range and I'm afraid that it
might affect me in the bad way well just
if there's no way it wouldn't yeah so it
will it's just up to you to take control
of it instead of controlling you so yeah
this is a very interesting
conversational point that you and I
could continue riffing on but even just
having your perspective on why you don't
have one is so so critical right it's
you're fighting against in so many ways
like cultural norm I love that I do it
too okay couple quick things on the way
out what is one skill that you think
that young people and even adults should
know moving into the exponential
technology age oh this is a tough
question one skill I think it doesn't so
my perspective on things
it doesn't matter how smart we are
doesn't matter how cool and how advanced
technologically we are I think four so
we should stay kind to each other yeah
doesn't matter how smart you are if you
do not kind nobody gonna deal with you I
think people should still remember about
moral standards be nice to each other
and of course love each other this is I
think this is most important thing if we
do this over us we can figure out but
sometimes this is much harder to figure
out when any science when any any
technological challenge ever
unfortunately yeah yeah yeah and things
like the ancient multi thousand year old
traditions of meditation and
connectedness to you know spiritual
transcendence they can help us with our
ability to be kind and compassionate
another and yeah this is I'm afraid
maybe we in our modern society we start
to think what kind of things and it
might have to do with the since the
Industrial Revolution the just
everything having to be productive if he
capitalism efficient has to make money
and yeah and that has made us in a sense
it's made us more part of the economic
machinery than it has made us
spiritually enlightened yeah because us
throws it away from nature and into the
metropolis of do to contribute in all
the monolithic buildings without atriums
and without plant gardens and rock walls
and fun and animal therapy with the
forest therapy you know together okay
and the last two questions is are we in
a simulation ah this is if behind the
similar bitter borders that very
recently I think scientists from Israel
published a work showing that if we in
simulation be computer power what needs
to create with simulation requires more
molecule and more atoms when currently I
in the universe so it means it should be
universe with several times bigger than
current universe in order to do with
simulations we predict we say okay if in
simple terms if there is one part the
cone you would like to predict its
motion we will need the computation
power it would require at least three
particles you know so and this is how is
showing okay probably we are not in
simulation but we in a simulation in a
way with everything we see if you and do
this is this is happening through our
interaction proven neurons right this is
now our mind only what we see if you
undo this is only in our mind and our
mind simulate this picture so it's yes
or no in the same time yes and on same
time
yeah we've we've heard it a couple times
that that the experiences are right here
inside of our skull and then we create
that and on the other point the
rendering aspect is kind of interesting
that you are just rendering what you see
in experience so that you are not
rendering anything else except this room
in MIT right now yeah and then once you
go out then you start rendering the
other things which saves on that
computational absolute power side of
things
so there's a couple ways to to poke and
prod at this scientifically that I'm
very interested in last question what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
humans
I still believe Cubans I still believe
humans yeah because and this is what we
starting with standing ourselves because
we believe problem was we do think like
we're after Medieval Renaissance started
and Renaissance started because people
start talking on themselves start
exploring themselves it was prohibited
by Georg for so many centuries and
that's why we standing for brain one of
the most beautiful parts of our body
yeah so probably was yeah and there's
currently eight billion different view
everybody unique everybody special
special and unique and have their own
creative potential that can be
flourished and a hundred billion before
the eight billion that no the beautiful
civilization that we have yeah
Wow he really well this has been such a
fascinating show thank you thank you for
my fake thank you who is such an honor
it was such an honor and we learned a
ton from this show optical voltage
sensors optogenetics expansion
microscopy all these new novel tools and
methods for imaging
interfacing and just what's actually at
the edge and how do we get that edge
back down to the general population to
get using it this has been super
fascinating thanks everyone for tuning
and we greatly appreciate it go and
share more conversations around neural
imaging and interfacing with your
friends your family your co-workers on
social media start sharing and talking
about these conversations more give us
your thoughts in the comments below
check out curios links below as well in
the bio also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in we had a
part of our conversation was about the
United States working together with
China figure out who these people are
across the seas that we can work with
and collaborate with that are building
really important Perl platforms that
bring us together and help us work
together to support them support
simulation our links are below as well
support us so we can keep doing cool
things like going to Westlake University
and conducting some of these interviews
that would be fascinating and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace right that was so good
you are awesome